What about what I house sat for
the guy that own Tgi Fridays.
He was on a board of directors.
Yeah.
When I lived on 44 35 far way
road and Snowmass village,
Colorado,
I house sat and the guy,
the two years I was there,
he came a week and a half.
He came for three days and his
daughters came for three days.
They spent 2000 on booze.
They all got drunk and they left two
days later and I was talking to the
daughter and she's like, yeah, this is,
my dad's got houses all over the place.
He had three in Colorado alone,
like crust. It crested Butte,
Snowmass village and he has a house on
the other side to ski over there because
he liked to different types of bout it.
Jesus Christ.
That world when people get that famous,
when they get that rich,
when they get that the point where they
live in some sort of weird Lala land,
he had a brand new jeep
delivered every year.
And part of my agreement was I had a
driver like 50 miles a month to keep make
sure because when he came to town he
didn't want no problems with none of his
houses. So we had a different
fucking house sitter it every,
and if you don't need a background
check on, you know, I listened to me,
I fucking grandfathered in to the house
because my buddy from Jersey had it and
his girlfriend came out to
visit and he knocked her up.
But the guy was difficult to get ahold
of because he was in England and whatnot.
So my friend just said to me, just just
moving. Don't say Dick when he comes in,
he'll see it's you and tell him I had
to leave and shit, keep my deposit.
So I stayed there for like two
months and he came and he's like,
who the fuck are you?
And I told him what had happened and that
we couldn't get ahold of him cause he
was in England and he asked me
for a couple of names. I would,
I had already lived in
snow mass for about a year.
I left and then came back. So I had
a couple of nights references for me,
gave me the thing and then left
and I was not allowed in this home.
So part of the deal was I had
an apartment over the garage.
I could use this car and it was 18 hours
a month to be the shoveling snow or
1818 hours a month of work or so it
was essentially a shoveling snow in the
winter and the long in the summer he would
give me little assignments like paint
the wall or whatever I would do, keep
the trim up and ship. It was zero rent.
I think he paid me 800 a month and I got
to get a day job and ski and Shit like
that though I would tape
it was a volunteer fireman.
You're a volunteer
fireman because all right,
so cocaine was 1,880 pounds at the
time and Snowmass and my buddy said,
give it to me for 800 and Jersey.
So I would go back and forth
and I was making all this on it.
The people found that the guy
that they blew up, they, they,
they put a pipe bomb in this
guy's car and they blew him up.
His name was Steven Gray Buck. He left
a big gap in this fucking drug place.
So I was telling him,
Oh yeah,
they killed this poor bastard in Colorado
and Aspen 36 days before he was to
stand trial,
but they could never get him for cocaine.
He was making 6 million every six weeks.
I spoke about this on
a once every six weeks.
In 1984 they arrested him the first
time and 83 they brought him to Denver.
They found 9 million altogether cash.
Then in [inaudible] 84 was when
he went. Every night he'd work out. He was
a good looking dude that kept in shape.
He had 20 different cars and every
night he'd give her the guy at the door,
$5 to start the car.
The night the guy took the night off,
he started his own car, they put a pipe
bomb in his car and blew him up. He lived,
he made it all the way to the hospital,
but something went so deep up his ass,
but it just bled to death.
Ooh.
So it left this gap. So this guy
approached him and then he's like, man,
these people are mad at yet.
They want to do business with you.
You're cutting them out.
So I had to talk to them and they said,
listen for you to buy. We didn't,
we never do a face to face.
So they haven't Aspen club and they
have a place called the CEO of the Aspen
Club is still,
you know,
in those days these places were
a thousand a month to walk in.
And I knew a girl that used to go to the
Aspen club and she used to tell me that
she used to take showers right
next to Barbie Benton. I'm a Barbi.
Benton Benton had a beautiful Bush.
She would tell me every night,
Bobby Benton's got a beautiful
fucking bushes. Perfect.
So there's the Aspen club and the
Snowmass clubs. No, mass club has golfing,
you know, condos around the thing. It
was like 900 a month to be a member.
I couldn't have been a member.
So the only way I could become a member
with my being a volunteer fireman,
then they'd give you admission. And so
for 90 days I had a train, you know,
go up two flights, this thing
on a ladder, carry a rope.
But basically it was putting out,
when tourists come,
they don't know how to
fucking turn on the fireplace.
So they clean out the sharks and they
put them in and then these people would
put them in a dumpster. So tentative
plan or you're doing this dumpster fires,
that's all you're doing.
But you got access to the Snowmass club.
So basically when we got there was
walking to this film mass club,
give the girl a $10,000 but
on your gym clothes workout,
by the time you got back to your locker,
the coke was in the locker,
it was all and they were all and everybody
involved. Everybody was involved.
So the girl that worked,
it's that she was getting a piece
of weapon we had to do was her hi,
how you doing Joe? Yeah. Okay, wow.
And then later on I go in the locker at
the coke would be that I'd get like a
half, eight ounces, you know, I
was no dealer and I take it home.
But then I started getting coked up every
time there was a fire I went through
like two fives both dumps is,
and this is 16 idiots with a full fire
hose. I'm like, is this necessary?
They even gave me like
a little fire truck,
like a little Toyota truck with like
a bell on it to go to the fires.
After like the third
five stopped showing up
for two months. They could, where are
you zero? The base where he lives.
And I'm just starting to cope.
Get my dick sucked.
You want me to go put out a fire
and a dumpster? Go Fuck you.
So they came over and took the dumpster
and then I went to work for this other
Dude Dick. There was three decks. The
Guy I worked for was Dick [inaudible],
Dick Kelly and Dick Boone was demand.
So I had a buddy used to go,
you're surrounded by
Dick Dick, Dick, Dick.
So Dick Kelly had one of those snow
companies and they wanted me to go and uh,
I don't know what that called Joe Rogan.
So straighten me out. It's a high low,
that's shovel snow. What's
a high low, high low boy?
And the warehouse was, oh shit.
Ball truck pushed it snow around.
So he was another poor bastard that
made a mistake and hired me that winter.
And yeah, I had to be that fought
in the morning. Four in the morning.
I'm on my second grandmother blow. He'd
be in front of my house beeping. Bam.
I'm going to go fuck herself.
I'm not working tonight.
He came and took his truck.
I was on a roll up then.
It's not a fucking row for like
plowed snow guys who had snow trucks when
it would snow out. Man, that was the,
you aren't getting any sleep.
Uh,
there was a bunch of guys that I knew
in Colorado on shop Boston from Boston.
Yeah, that's, that's, that's
a business. It's a business
in the wintertime. You know,
as soon as you get snow,
most people start to fucking get unhappy
and people would look out the window
with the coffee and making sure you're
out there with the truck up the driveway,
pushing snow around. My
Buddy Jimmy, he had a,
there was one of his side businesses. He
was an electrician, the side business.
He had a,
he had a plow on his pickup truck
and we just fucking plow people out.
Do People's driveways. You know,
it's, I was, I went home this year,
March 20th I went home to Jersey.
I had to do is show one night or Nyack
and me and Arya hooked up
in the city way that a bull.
We walked around the city and the snow
had just started to snow. You know, and I,
by the time I got up the next morning,
it's no like a foot.
I'd never seen anything like that. Like
when I was a kid in jersey, if it snowed,
that shit was there.
Like that shit stayed for state dance.
There was no school stacked up
on the side of the sidewalk.
Nerdy snow from my town won't let up.
Fucking ounce of Snow Lan,
not an inch. Really bad.
Fucking tremendous that night the
roads would clean. He's color.
I'll never forget how when I left
Jersey and 83 like if it snowed,
like let's say if it's snowed and
had had to take the bus up here,
I would just call you and say Joe,
which smelling and you'd
expect me at 11 and you know,
everything was late whenever
it snowed in Jersey.
He has this big metropolitan area in
New York City and it snowed that cripple
the city. They didn't know how
to hand newspapers wouldn't come.
People get pissed off the New York Post.
I remember moving to Snowmass and getting
a job at aspen electric and that meant
I had to get on a bus in Snowmass,
go to the bottom of the hill,
transfer and shoot the bus to Snowmass.
I did this and I remember
the first time we got,
I woke up one day and you know in
Colorado you wake up one morning,
this 12 inches, it's just
another day. Just another day.
And I remember the 1983 they
couldn't fucking clean up New York,
but I'll never forget that morning
waking up and ask him like at six 30 and
Snowmass and going,
they're not going to expect me to about
10 and I walked in there at 10 the
people like, what the fuck have you
been? And I'm like, it snowed out.
The buses are running late.
They go,
everybody else here came out of the
bus and they all got here on time.
They fucking busted me right out like
Colorado was that far ahead of the game?
Well, they're just so
used to it. It was so,
but like here I was living in this
big metropolitan city that four inches
crippled.